en este vídeo quiero presentarles la
idea de la covarianza entre dos
variables aleatorias que está definido
como el valor esperado de la distancia o
el producto de las distancias de cada
una de las variables aleatorias de su
media o de su valor esperado ahora vamos
a escribir esto vamos a poner la equis
en un color diferente
así que el valor esperado de la variable
aleatoria x
- el valor esperado de esta variable x x
y esa es la variable aleatoria de color
verde por la distancia de y hasta su
valor esperado la población media de g
si esto no tiene sentido para ustedes en
este momento siempre podemos revisar y
pensar acerca de lo que está ocurriendo
acá ponemos algunos números aquí y
hacemos las matemáticas pero en la
realidad esto quiere decir que tanto
varían juntas tenemos una equis y una
por cada uno de los puntos de la
información y tomamos toda la población
cada equis y ya van juntas mutuamente
son una coordenada que escribimos aquí
vamos a ver un ejemplo digamos que esta
x va a estar por encima de su media y
lleva a estar por debajo de su media de
esta población vamos a tomar una
instancia de las variables aleatorias xy
le tomamos una muestra del universo y
encontramos que x es igual a 1 kg
es igual
vamos a decir que es igual a 3
y digamos que sabemos de antemano que el
valor esperado de x es cero
y el valor esperado de ella va a ser
igual a 4 bueno en esta situación que es
lo que acaba de pasar no conocemos la
covarianza total sólo tenemos una
muestra aquí de estas variables
aleatorias pero lo que acaba de pasar es
tenemos 1 menos
no vamos a calcular todo el valor
esperado pero vamos a tomar los valores
de esta muestra y ver qué sucede cuando
hacemos esto que está dentro del valor
esperado tenemos 1 - 0
1 - 0 es igual a 1 x 3 menos 4 que es
menos 11 x menos 1 va a ser igual a
menos 1 esto que nos dice nos dice que
al menos para esta muestra de nuestras
variables aleatorias x siguen que x está
por encima de su valor esperado cuando
yo estaba por debajo de su propio valor
esperado si seguimos haciendo esto y que
ocurrirá lo mismo para toda la población
entonces tendré sentido que tu vida una
covarianza negativa ya que cuando una
sube la otra baja
cuando una baja la otra sube si ambas
subieran juntas tendrían una covarianza
positiva lo mismo si ambas fueran hacia
abajo al mismo tiempo sería una cobardía
esa positiva y el grado en el que van
juntas es lo que nos dice la magnitud de
la covarianza en este vídeo quiero unir
esta fórmula que es la definición de la
covarianza con todo lo que hemos hecho
con la regresión por mínimos cuadrados y
este es digamos que una matemática
divertida para mostrar todas estas
conexiones y podemos ver que la
definición de ccoo varianza realmente se
vuelve útil y yo pienso que esto es
debido en gran parte a lo que se
muestran las regresiones y todas estas
cosas ya las hemos visto antes solo que
de diferente manera en este vídeo vamos
a reescribir todo esto esta definición
de ccoo varianza voy a reescribir lo de
manera que esto va a ser lo mismo
que el valor esperado que el valor
esperado
y ahora vamos a multiplicar estos
binomios de aquí el valor esperado de
nuestra variable aleatoria x
multiplicada por nuestra variable
aleatoria y menos y voy a hacer la parte
de x primero más x por el valor esperado
de y negativo nos queda menos pongamos
los con los colores correspondientes
menos x por el valor esperado de y
esteban verde
el valor esperado de este negativo viene
de este valor negativo de acá y tenemos
- el valor esperado de x x menos el
valor esperado de x
y en verde
y finalmente multiplicamos el valor
esperado de x negativo por menos el
valor esperado de g
que nos da más el valor esperado de x
por el valor esperado del metal de un
poco pero creo que es importante
mantener el código de colores para
hacerlo más entendible por lo tanto este
es el valor esperado de todo esto que
está aquí el valor esperado de todo esto
que está aquí adentro vamos a tratar de
simplificar esto el valor esperado de un
conjunto de variables aleatorias es la
suma o resta de sus correspondientes
valores esperados al aplicar esto en
este caso todo esto va a ser igual a el
valor esperado y recuerden que en
algunos contextos eso lo pueden ver como
la media aritmética o en una
distribución continua como la
probabilidad de la suma ponderada o la
probabilidad de la integral ponderada
todo esto lo hemos visto anteriormente
vamos a reescribir esto que va a ser
igual al valor esperado de las variables
aleatorias x x x ye y seguimos
manteniendo el código de colores después
sabemos menos x por el valor esperado de
g lo escribimos
- el valor esperado
x por el valor esperado de eje x por el
valor esperado de g
vamos a conservar el color
y ahora tenemos menos el valor esperado
de esto
el valor esperado de x
aquí el chiquito le escribimos el valor
esperado de x x
y aquí puede ser algo confuso con todos
los valores esperados anidados entre sí
pero una forma de verlo es que aquellas
cosas que ya tenemos su valor esperado
pues los podemos ver simplemente como
unos números pues son números conocidos
ya que el valor esperado de un valor
esperado es lo mismo que el valor
esperado vamos a escribir esto aquí para
tenerlo siempre en mente el valor
esperado del valor esperado de x va a
ser igual al valor esperado de x pueden
ustedes ver esto como la media de la
población de la variable por lo que esto
va a ser algo conocido el valor esperado
de esto pues va a ser el mismo por
ejemplo si la media de la población o el
valor esperado fuera 5 sería lo mismo
que el valor esperado de 5 pues el valor
esperado de 5 a hacer 5 espero que esto
haya aclarado un poco esos valores
esperados anidados ya estamos por
terminar lo primero que hicimos fue
tomar el valor esperado de esto y
después desarrollar esta multiplicación
de binomios y finalmente estamos
completando esta parte donde nos queda
el valor esperado de todo esto de acá
el valor esperado de x
por el valor esperado
y ahora veamos si podemos simplificar
esto de acá
este va a ser el valor esperado del
producto de estas dos variables
aleatorias y lo vamos a dejar así como
está por el momento y las cosas que
vamos a dejar así vamos a escribir las
de nuevo acá el valor esperado de x
porque y ahora que tenemos aquí tenemos
el valor esperado de x por el valor
esperado de pero como lo mencionamos
anteriormente este va a ser un valor el
valor esperado de iu así que podemos
sacarlo si esto fuera el valor esperado
de 3x sería lo mismo que 3 por el valor
esperado de x por lo que aquí ponemos
menos el valor esperado de i
el valor esperado de g por el valor
esperado de x valor esperado de x pueden
verlo como que estamos factor izando o
sacando este valor
y ahora tenemos menos
exactamente lo mismo acá podemos
actualizar este valor esperado de xy
sacarlo de esta parte de manera que nos
queda menos el valor esperado de x por
el valor esperado de y el valor esperado
de g
y trato a seguir el código de colores
porque se está poniendo un poco confuso
esto con todas las
y finalmente pues bueno lo mismo tenemos
el valor esperado de x por el valor
esperado de iu y esto va a ser el
producto de estos dos valores esperados
más el valor esperado de x
multiplicado por el valor esperado de g
y que nos queda acá tenemos menos el
valor esperado por el valor esperado de
x menos el valor esperado de x por el
valor esperado de iu y estas dos cosas
son exactamente lo mismo estamos
restando estos dos veces y tenemos una
más
todas estas tres son iguales aquí
tenemos el valor esperado de g por el
valor esperado de x
aquí tenemos el valor esperado de 10 por
el valor esperado de x sólo que en
diferente orden y aquí tenemos el valor
esperado de jett por el valor esperado
de x igual en otro orden los restantes
dos veces y los sumamos una vez o
también podemos verlo como que este
elemento se cancela con este otro
elemento
lo que nos queda es que la covarianza de
estas dos variables aleatorias es igual
al valor esperado voy a regresar a los
colores para que quede de nuevo más
claro esto
x
por qué
el valor esperado del producto de xy
menos
que nos queda el valor esperado de y lo
ponemos en el verde que les corresponde
- el valor esperado de jeff por el valor
esperado de x por el valor esperado de x
y podemos calcular estos valores
esperados si es que conocemos la
distribución de las probabilidades las
funciones de densidad para cada una de
estas variables aleatorias o si tenemos
toda la población que estamos mostrando
de donde estamos tomando instancias de
estas dos variables digamos que tenemos
una muestra de estas dos variables como
podríamos estimar las si las estamos
estimando el valor esperado y digamos
que tenemos muchos puntos de datos
muchas coordenadas y veremos como esto
se relaciona con la regresión y el valor
esperado de x porque se puede aproximar
con la media de la muestra
del producto de xy
la media de la muestra de xy tomamos
cada una de nuestras asociaciones xy le
hacemos el producto y encontramos la
media de todos ellos y esto se acaba es
el valor esperado de ayer que puede
aproximarse por la media de la muestra
de iu y el valor esperado de x puede
de x por lo tanto a que se puede
aproximar la covarianza de dos variables
aleatorias esto de aquí es la media del
producto la media del producto de las
variables de las muestras menos la media
de las muestras de y la media de las
muestras de g
la media de las muestras de x y esto ya
les debe de parecer familiar porque qué
es esto
este es el numerador
el numerador
de cuando queremos calcular la pendiente
de la línea de regresión cuando queremos
calcular la pendiente de la línea de
regresión vamos a reescribir la fórmula
aquí para poderla recordar era
literalmente la media del producto de
las variables aleatorias o de nuestros
puntos de los datos menos la media de
las veces por las medias de las x todo
esto dividido entre la media de x
cuadrada o incluso pueden verlo como la
media de la multiplicación de las x pero
por conveniencia vamos a escribirlo x
cuadrada menos la media de x elevado al
cuadrado
y esto es como calculamos la pendiente
de nuestra línea de regresión
una mejor manera de ver esto es asumir
en nuestra línea de regresión que los
puntos que tenemos son muestras de un
universo entero de puntos posibles y
podemos decir que nos estamos
aproximando a la pendiente de la línea
de regresión este como son rarito indica
que es una aproximación y podrán
encontrarlo en algunos libros de texto
así nos estamos aproximando a la línea
de regresión de la población a partir de
una muestra de este ahora de todo lo que
hemos hecho hasta el momento esto de acá
es la covarianza o es un estimado de la
covarianza de xy y que será esto de aquí
abajo bueno podemos reescribir esto muy
fácilmente este denominador lo podremos
reescribir como la media de x por equis
que es lo mismo que x cuadrada menos la
media de x por la media de x y eso lo
que significa esta media de x al
cuadrado bueno ustedes lo pueden ver
como la covarianza
x x ángeles está muy buena esto ya lo
hemos visto anteriormente esto lo vimos
hace ya bastantes vídeos cuando
aprendimos por primera vez que era esto
la convergencia de una variable
aleatoria consigo mismo por lo que esto
es la varianza de la variable de la
historia x y eso lo pueden verificar
ustedes mismos si cambian esta jr por
una equis esto se convierte en x menos
el valor esperado de x por x menos el
valor esperado de x o x menos el valor
esperado de x al cuadrado lo que es la
definición de varianza por lo que otra
manera de ver la pendiente de nuestra
línea de regresión puede verse
literalmente como la covarianza de
nuestras dos variables aleatorias
dividido entre la varianza de x entre la
varianza de x
o lo que es lo mismo la variable
aleatoria independiente esto es la
pendiente de nuestra línea de regresión
y creo que esto es bastante interesante
ver como cosas que vemos en diferentes
partes de la estadística en realidad
están conectadas